we're asked to solve for s and we have s
squared minus 2 s minus 35 is equal to 0
now this is the first time that you've
seen this type of what's essentially a
quadratic equation you might be tempted
to try to solve for s using traditional
algebraic means but the best way to
solve this especially when it's
explicitly equal to 0 is to factor the
left-hand side and then think about
whether think about the fact that those
binomials that you factor into that they
have to be equal to 0 so let's just do
that so how can we factor this we've
seen it several ways
I'll show you kind of the standard way
we've been doing it by grouping and then
there's a little bit of a shortcut when
you have a 1 as a coefficient over here
so when you look at something when you
do something by grouping when you factor
by grouping you think about two numbers
whose sum is going to be equal to
negative 2 so you think about two
numbers whose sum a plus B is equal to
negative 2 and whose product is going to
be equal to negative 35 a times B is
equal to negative 35 since the product
is a negative number one has to be
positive one has to be negative and so
if you think about it ones that are
about two apart you have five and
negative seven I think that'll work five
plus negative seven is equal to negative
two so the factor by grouping you split
this middle term into a we can split
this into a let me write it this way we
have s squared and then this middle term
right here I'll do it in pink this
middle term right there I can write it
as plus five s minus seven s and then we
have the minus 35 and of course all of
that is equal to zero now we call it
factoring by grouping because we group
it so we can group these first two terms
and these first two terms they have a
common factor of s so let's factor that
out you have s times s plus five that's
the same thing as s squared plus 5 s now
in this second in the second two terms
right here you have a common factor of
negative seven so let's factor that out
so you have negative seven times s plus
five and of course all of that is
equal to zero now we have two terms here
where both of them have s plus five is a
factor both of them have this s plus 5
as a factor so we can factor that out so
let's do that so you have s plus 5 times
times this s times this S right here
right F plus 5 times s would give you
this term and then you have minus that 7
right there - that 7i undistributed the
S plus 5 and then this is going to be
equal this is going to be equal to 0 now
that we've factored it we just have to
think a little bit about what happens
when you take the product of two numbers
I mean s plus 5 is the number S minus 7
is another number and we're saying that
the product of those two numbers is
equal to 0 if I told you that I had two
numbers if I told you that I had the
numbers a times B and that they equal to
zero what do we know about either A or B
or both of them well at least one of
them has to be equal to 0 or both of
them have to be equal to 0 so the fact
that this number times that number is
equal to 0 tells us that either either s
plus 5 is equal to 0 or or and maybe
both of them or s minus 7 is equal to 0
or divided in just green or s minus 7 is
equal to 0 and so you have these two
equations actually you could say and or
it could be or either way and both of
them could be equal to 0 so let's see
let's see how we can solve for this well
we can just subtract 5 from both sides
of this equation right there and so you
get on the left hand side
you have s is equal to negative 5 that
is one solution to the equation or you
have so you can add 7 to both sides of
that equation and you get s is equal to
7 so if s is equal to negative 5 or s is
equal to 7 then we have satisfied this
equation we can never even verify it if
you make s equal to negative 5 you have
positive 25 plus 10 we
35 - 35 that does equal zero if you have
749 - 14 - 35 does equal zero so we've
solved for s now I mentioned there's an
easier way to do it and when you have
when you have something like this where
you have one as the leading coefficient
you just you don't have to do this
two-step factoring let me just show you
an example if I just have X plus X plus
a times X plus B what is that equal to x
times X is x squared x times B is BX a
times X is plus ax a times B is a B plus
a B so you get x squared plus these two
can be added plus a plus B X plus a B
and that's the pattern that we have
right here we have one as a leading
coefficient here we have one as a
leading coefficient here so once we have
our two numbers that add up to negative
two so once we have our two numbers that
add up to negative two that's our a plus
B and we have our product that gets to
negative 35 then we can straight just
factor it into the product of those two
things so it'll be or the product of the
binomials where those will be the A's
and the B so it'll be so we figured out
it's five and negative seven five plus
negative seven is negative 2 5 times
negative 7 is negative 35 so we could
have just straight factored at this
point 2 - well actually this was the
case of s so we could have factored it
straight to the case of s plus 5 times s
minus 7 we could have done that straight
away and we've gotten to that right
there and of course that whole thing was
equal to 0 so that have been a little
bit of a shortcut but but factoring by
grouping will it'll-it'll it's a
completely appropriate way to do it as
well